premiers grands départs en vacances pour
les parisiens il s'est poursuivi hier
tout au long de la journée et même ce
matin car nombreux étaient ceux qui
avaient voulu partir la conscience
tranquille
une fois leur devoir électoral accompli
hélas il n'est pas de route sans
accident malgré toutes les vigilances et
les moyens mis à la disposition des
conducteurs pour régler ou fluidifier
une circulation difficile mais il n'y a
pas de roses sans épines et l'on est sûr
de partir vers le soleil en emmenant
avec soi tout l'équipage nécessaires aux
joies des vacances c'est un avant goût
de ces joie qu'ont voulu aussi goûté les
parisiens les piscines avait un air de
côte d'azur des plus réussies l'eau y
était tentante agréable bienfaisante et
les bains de soleil dispensait alors
amateurs les douceurs d'une chaleur
qualiméditerranée m
quand on veut partir tous les moyens
sont bons et après les longues files
pare-choc contre pare-choc
comme il est bon de se retrouver dans le
calme des bois avec un appétit aiguisé
par les effluves de la forêt
plus près beaucoup plus près le bois de
boulogne providence des parisiens au
frais à ceux qui aiment tout à la fois
la rêverie sur l'eau et l'activité des
muscles les plaisirs du canotage
ici aussi il faisait chaud même en se
découvrant d'un fils bien trop chaud
quelle tentation trempé des plis
douloureux dans ses tongs fraîche où
nagent les signes indifférente aux
misères des hommes à paris même place de
la concorde l'été enfin était au rendez
vous